PROFESSOR: Let's do
it biogeometrically.
There's a nice geometric
interpretation to this thing.
So it comes from thinking
of this in phase space.
So this is motion
in the x, p plain.
So let's think of the
motion of this oscillator
in the x, p plane.
Here, we have that the energy is
equal to p squared over 2m plus
1/2 m omega squared x squared.
So this is an ellipse in the x--
a closed orbit.
A constant omega solution
is an ellipse in this plane.
That's because it's
some something squared
plus something squared
with different coefficient.
So here it is.
It's some sort of
ellipse like that.
Semi-major axis,
semi-minor axis.
I actually don't know which is
the major and which is a minor.
But two semi axes.
Well when p is equal to 0, what
is the value of x defines this.
So a is the value of x when p0--
so it's 2 square root of
2E over m omega squared.
And b is the value of
p when x is equal to 0.
So it's just square root of 2mE.
And here is the particle doing
this motion in this orbit.
As time goes by,
the position x goes
from a maximum to a minimum and
return with the momentum going
like that.
It's a nice representation
of the physical motion
as moving on the ellipse.
That's what this
system is doing.
So you could ask, when you
have something like that,
you would ask, OK,
you have an ellipse,
what's the area of the ellipse?
Area is pi ab.
That's the formula for
the area from an ellipse.
Pi times the product of the
semi-major and semi-minor axes.
That clearly generalizes
correctly to a circle.
And it's the right formula.
And then when we multiply
it, look what happens.
There is-- do I have--
yeah, I think I have
everything here--
pi ab-- I get 2 pi.
The m's cancel.
The E's don't cancel.
E over omega, hey, that's
our adiabatic invariant.
2 pi E over omega,
the area of this thing
is our adiabatic invariant.
That's a very nice
classical picture.
You have motion in phase space.
And as omega changes, maybe
the ellipse will change.
But the area tends
to keep constant.
That's what's happening.
That's a statement of this
result. So that's nice.
It also can be written as a
formula, which is kind of neat.
So the area of the
ellipse is this.
But the area of the
ellipse, it can also
be written in a
slightly different way.
Let's assume the orbit is
going like this, for example.
The motion is going like that.
And then, what is the
area of the ellipse?
The area of this top part
is the integral of pdx,
is the integral of the top part.
But we'll write it,
that's just the top.
But if I think of
this as an integral
over the whole
counter, I would be
having the whole
integral of pdx like that
into over the whole counter.
I integrate here and I
get the area of the top.
And when they
integrate down here,
I'm having the x's
that are negative
and p's that are negative.
So I'm getting the area
of the bottom part.
So actually this
full counter integral
over the whole boundary gives
you the full area of the thing.
The top area in one part, the
bottom area in the bottom part.
So that's the area
of the ellipse.
So we get the idea that
the integral of pdx
is roughly equal to
2 pi E over omega.
That's exactly equal when the
system is time independent.
But then if it's not
time independent,
this is an equation that can
help us think of this system
and identify an
adiabatic invariant,
because we identify
this quantity
as an adiabatic invariant.
The more general statement
in classical mechanics
is that this kind of integral
is an adiabatic invariant.
So in classical
mechanics, people
search from adiabatic invariants
by integrals over phase space.
It's a nice way
to think of them.
But let's go quantum mechanical.
It's the analogies that
we mentioned before.
Let's use them.
So here we go.
We've said a little about this.
And we'll say a bit more.
So for quantum mechanics,
what do we have?
Well, we had the oscillator.
We mentioned it.
And we said that E over omega
was h bar omega occupation
number plus 1/2 over omega
and is therefore h n plus 1/2.
So in quantum mechanics,
the adiabatic invariant
becomes a quantum number.
And the adiabatic theorem
in quantum mechanics
is essentially going to say that
if you have quantum numbers,
you are almost guaranteed, if
the system is slowly varying,
to remain in that quantum state.
We're going to try to make that
clearer, but that's the spirit.
Quantum numbers don't change
under adiabatic approximation.
Quantum numbers don't change.
So in some sense, this whole
story was developed today.
The classical
intuition, maybe it's
a little less obvious, is
integrals over phase space,
a trajectory in phase space of
a particle conserves the area.
And here, in quantum
mechanics is the idea
that if you have
a quantum number,
you're going to find
it difficult to have
a change in quantum numbers.
But that's all we've
been doing with time
dependent perturbation theory,
change of quantum number.
So we'll think a little bit
about it why that happened.
Now, there's more here
that is interesting.
You remember your
WKB approximation.
You did the quantization
when you had a system,
say, with two turning
points, a and b.
Bohr-Summerfeld
quantization, remember
you assume there's a decaying
thing here, therefore
a cosine in the middle
with a pi over 4,
a decaying, another
close n with a pi over 4.
And the compatibility gave you
the quantization condition.
Now, what was that
quantization condition?
It was 1 over h bar integral
of the local momentum px a/b
equals n plus 1/2 pi.
So if you multiply
by 2 this integral,
that is the full integral
over the back and forth
of p of x dx is equal to
2 pi h bar n plus 1/2.
That formula, if you remember,
gave the oscillator exactly.
But look how nice
you see the intuition
that this quantity of classical
mechanics that we said
is the idea adiabatic
invariant also
shows in semi-classical
quantization telling you
that that quantity,
yes, doesn't want
to change because, in fact, it
represents a quantum number.
So the WKB approximation is
also reinforcing the idea
that first this quantity,
this integral over phase space
is an adiabatic
invariant and second
that it represents a
quantum number that
doesn't want to change.
Let me make one last
comment before we
start a real calculation in
quantum mechanics about this.
Transitions, we
studied transitions.
And transitions are
the kind of things
that don't happen
easily when you have
an adiabatic approximation.
So what did we have
for transitions?
For transitions, we
had the probability
to go from some initial
to some final state
was the integral from
0 to t e to the i omega
f i t prime delta h of t prime
f i over i h bar v t prime.
Assume you have a
constant perturbation.
So you can take this quantity
out of the integral, delta h
f i of t prime squared
over h squared.
And you get this integral of
e to the i omega f i t prime.
And that integral
can roughly be done.
And you've done it a few times--
f i t minus 1 over
omega f i squared.
So this is what we got for
a constant perturbation.
And a constant
perturbation finds
it hard to induce energy
jumping transition.
So if you have a
discrete system,
making that transition is
hard, because however time you
let go, this quantity is--
maybe there's a square here.
Yes, there's a square--
this quantity is
bounded in time.
This doesn't grow beyond
the particular quantity.
But here you have a suppression
because the energies
are different.
And if the energies
are fairly different,
this is very suppressed.
The way our calculation
escape that,
we'd said, oh, if
you have a continuum
behind these
discrete states, then
you can make a
transition because you
don't have to have a
large change of energy.
So our transitions
are things that
illustrate a little
bit what we're
getting to that it's difficult
to change energy levels
for slowly varying processes.
In fact, if this Hamiltonian
was not exactly a time constant,
it's still difficult to bank a
transition, because, you know,
if it varies slowly, this
is still roughly true.
Over some period of time,
you could say, well,
it's the average value.
In order to get an efficient
transition between two energy
levels, you had to
put the Hamiltonian--
a cosine of omega t at
the right frequency.
And then you induce
the transition.
But slowly varying
Hamiltonian finds
it difficult to
induce transitions.
All right, so this is the end of
our introduction to the subject
of adiabatic evolution.
And now we're going
to try to calculate
how a quantum state changes
under adiabatic evolution.